we are delighted to have with us today
Sara Chase who is going to speak on the
topic government in the public interest
under assault question marks and as many
of you know sara cheese has a
distinguished and very interesting
background with which she is going to
inform our thinking about what is
happening in the world today in the book
that many of you have read i know some
of you are in Elena's Minsky's class and
the Fred peeps of state this is a
prize-winning book that makes a powerful
argument about how corruption breeds
extremism she has witnessed this
firsthand spending many years in the
Middle East she worked for the Joint
Chiefs of Staff Admiral Mike Mullen for
many years after he came to see her
point of view that corruption really is
a core problem in American foreign
policy and so I I think it's fair to
think of her now as a gadfly in chief of
American foreign domestic governments as
well we're going to let you say whatever
more you want to say about your
background and how that informs where
you are today I would just say one more
thing for those of you who not read this
book is beautifully written is informed
by deep experience and it has amazing
scholarly area dition she draws on her
work on medieval Islamic thought and
quotes scholars from hundreds of years
ago who saw at that time that corruption
was a danger to governance and so please
join me in welcoming Sarah Jason
thank you very much and thank you all
for being here I mean it's not like
words or you know something you don't
have enough of to absorb in in this life
so I really appreciate those of you who
weren't compelled to show up those of
you in YouTube and you know Corruption
favorite topic right and so we are gonna
spend most of the afternoon talking
about it but but first I'd like to kind
of take a step back to talk about that
stuff money I would like to suggest that
we're living at a time and it obviously
it's the root of all evil and I got that
and there's plenty I could do probably
plenty more scholarly work on on what
people think about money but I do think
that it adds and flows and that we're
living at a particular period in history
where money has displaced are you not
hearing me well oh I see okay so that
means I have to stay here or I can use
this one
you mean you're gonna like put me in a
cage back here Wow
so we're living at a time when money has
displaced supplanted if you will other
values in how we measure our social
standing right other values like wisdom
or contributions to the community or
creativity or insight you know public
service and it's really become the way
of measuring social standing it's the
way of keeping score if you will and by
the way it doesn't really matter where
it comes from I spent about two and a
half weeks in Nigeria literally asking
people everywhere North and South both
both major actually most major religions
different social classes whether the
meaning of money had changed in their
lifetime and the answers I got were both
emphatic and surprising it was
absolutely yes and it was things like
people use money to intimidate other
people oh really how by giving it to
them if somebody gives you money then
you can't tell the truth anymore wow
that's really interesting but I also got
that you know it used to be that it
mattered where your money came from and
everyone had a story about how he had
found money on the ground and was so
terrified about taking it home and not
being able to explain where the money
had come from it was like that when
Ellen did you lose some money yeah I
mean literally giving it to passersby
and now they say it doesn't matter
anymore what matters is that you bring
it home bring the money home to the
village people told me you know now
they're they're celebrating you know
there will be on television the fancy
weddings of very rich people they're
celebrating the people who loot the
public treasury that means what we're in
is a competition I mean I've heard a lot
of people say when is enough
and the point is it's not about what
you're gonna do with the money it's a
competition for zeros in bank accounts
it's not about need it's about winning
and that means there are no limits and
that has some really significant
implications in terms of how much
natural resources and human labour and
human creativity need to get converted
into cash in order to create more zeros
in the in the competitors bank accounts
to compete in this race elites
everywhere and I mentioned Nigeria but I
think you know everything I'm gonna say
applies to the United States elites are
rewriting rules or selectively enforcing
them in their own favor
that's what ordinary people mean when
they talk about corruption or rigged
systems or a swamp
that's what ordinary people mean but the
elites meanwhile at the same time are
also narrowing the definition of
corruption right so so while they're
busily rigging the system you have for
example what I thought was the most
significant event in the campaign season
I guess I was probably wrong given what
we're now learning about the campaign
season in 2016 but at the time it was
not you know the latest outrageous
statement or the latest leak it was in
fact a Supreme Court decision in June I
think of 2016 overturning the conviction
for corruption of Virginia then Virginia
Governor Bob McDonald eight to zero that
shocked me even more than the decision
itself the acts were constituted in
other words there was no question that
this guy had taken the governor had
taken a bunch of money like a hundred
and eighty thousand dollars worth of
stuff right you know his daughter's
wedding and free trips and loans and a
little bit of cash and this and that
in order to lean on the State Department
of Education to do clinical trials on
some quack medicine that the briber
to sell that the quid-pro-quo
was established in the conviction in
fact you know like he'd get a call from
the businessman in five minutes later
you know he'd make the call to the
Secretary of State for education but the
conviction was thrown out because the
Supreme Court did not deem that effort
to constitute official acts that's what
the bribery statute says it has to be in
return for an official act now if you're
calling your subordinate from your
telephone in you know the governor's
mansion I don't understand why that's
not an official act but that's where the
Supreme Court went as a result basically
to commit corruption legally in the
United States at this point you'd
basically need to be jailed for
stupidity
to actually do something that would now
count its corruption I think that you
know and some of you are taking a class
and one of you is teaching a class on
corruption in this room and I suspect
that some of your readings may seem a
little bit technical I think that's
another way that corruption is kind of
underestimated is it seen as a kind of
technical often an isolated thing that
isolated individuals do opportunistic
and therefore light liable to be
addressed with technical solutions so
you hear a lot of those or how many of
you have studied or taught fragile and
failing States that wonderful expression
so that's what I heard a lot about it
you know was oh they're fragile and
failing States and corruption sort of
seeps in like some kind of a you know
cancer or or or a disease I think none
of these definitions are sufficient to
what we're dealing with today I think
that what we're actually dealing with is
not so much fragile or failing
governments but rather extremely
successful criminal organizations that
are masquerading as government
corruption in sixty to seventy countries
that I've been looking at worldwide I
know that's pretty provocative language
but is the operating system of these
networks which are not indeed successful
in governing but that's not their
objective that's their objective that
stuff money money for network members
that is what they are that's their aim
by network what do I mean
in thieves of state I focus on vertical
integration of networks and that's
because that's what we discovered I mean
I fell into this issue in Afghanistan
not because I mean I was there to kind
of do reconstruction work I wasn't
planning on focusing on on rule of law
or governance or anything like that but
Afghans were screaming that's all they
could talk about was how they were being
shaken down by their government and what
and so I started working it and
eventually like eight years in I'm
working for the command at the military
command at what's called AI saff the
international military headquarters in
Kabul and we start working some
corruption cases and what we discovered
is so we went after a kind of two-bit
police official he was a border police
official you know what come on don't be
shy come on down front and there's
plenty of room both in front and around
the other side that's exactly right
or maybe some of some of you folks could
even scoot down just to make it there we
go
boy they disposed of it of a faculty
appointment really fast didn't you two
faculty appointments so we you know a
friend of mine had been mentoring Afghan
police in doing this pretty complex
you know white-collar crime stuff and
they learned how to do judicial wiretap
and they learn how to you know do bank
records and all the stuff they had this
great evidence on this relatively
unimportant border police official I
knew him
it's like I even said let's not even
bother with this this guy doesn't matter
oh we got all the evidence let's go for
it
so I watch president karzai throw
himself across the railroad tracks to
prevent that that arrests from going
down and I could not figure it out and
and eventually what kind of the epiphany
was the police police officer on the
street who shakes him down the clerk who
shakes you down when you need a an
official document the doctor who shakes
you down in order to be treated
they don't just put that money in their
pocket they owe some of it up the line
that's what I mean by vertical
integration and it turns out to be true
everywhere I've looked at this is that
the you know the cop in fact in it was
Becca Stan for example you have young
men going into debt to buy their
position in the police the village the
whole village will like chip in to get
their kid a job in the police then the
poor kid has to pay back the village and
continue paying the monthly things up
the line now what goes down the line in
return is impunity and that's why
President Karzai threw himself across
the railroad tracks because it doesn't
matter how unimportant that police
official is a down the line if there is
some indication to the system that the
guarantee of impunity is not a firm and
solid guarantee well heck they're gonna
stop sending their money up the line
that's the deal the whole system will
collapse so so that's what I learned
there and that's what I really talked
about in themes of state what I've been
working on since then is horizontal
integration so you know here we were in
Afghanistan we were looking primarily at
you know insurgents and things like that
but let's take Latin America where I've
looked you know more recently I've done
a bit of work on Honduras so in Latin
America for example US officials are
really concerned about
transnational organized crime right the
bad guys in that context are the drug
deal
just as the bad guys in the Afghan
context are the insurgents so from the
perspective of somebody who you know
goes after transnational organized crime
sorry I really have to like sitting for
this is terrible guys no it's not
terrible I'm used to wandering around a
little bit more but yeah and but I think
it's tough on some people because it it
goes all the way back so I'll stick with
it for now but but just imagine if you
will that I'm wandering this from the
perspective of you know cop shows on the
TV or people who focus on organized
crime the corrupt official is like the
supporting actor in the drama you know
the organized criminals they are the
lead and the corrupt official is the
supporting actor in arc you know here in
America we could get into a fistfight
probably probably even within this room
about who's worse for your health the
public sector or the private sector
right what I'm getting at is we see
those three sectors as fundamentally
separate and different and distinct in
these kleptocratic networks they weave
all the way together so it's not like
organized crime you know gets one person
here or one person there these are fully
integrated kleptocratic networks just as
an example there was a gigantic case in
New York a Honduras case where in the
son of the former president of Honduras
pled guilty to moving like over a ton of
cocaine into the United States in
combination with the biggest Mexican and
Colombian drug cartels and one of the
major banks was laundering the money so
that's the network right there
drug-dealing government officials and
the main private sector in Azerbaijan
another country I've looked at the
president's family owns 11 banks they
own the entire financial you know
finance
financial services industry so these
networks will look different in
different countries they will be more or
less consolidated like Azerbaijan's is
very consolidated Honduras is a little
bit more separate like the there's
overlap between public private and
criminal sectors in terms of personnel
but largely the network is held together
by a very thick tissue of exchanges now
and here's where we really get into
government by and for the people right
the job of the members of the network
who are in government office is to bend
their agencies or institutions to serve
not the public interest but the
interests of the network that's what I
mean by that's the rig system right
there and you know I have a couple I
didn't bring them but I have a couple of
infographics like powerpoints that look
at different countries and which sector
which you know government institutions
are fully captured almost always the
judiciary right because if you're gonna
guarantee impunity or be able to punish
the people you want to punish you need
to own the judiciary it's not always the
case and they don't get every single one
so for example in Egypt president Sisi
has been assiduously expanding the
jurisdiction of the military courts
because he can't control the civilian
courts there's still a little bit
independent they still have a certain
amount of professional you know ethics
and stuff like that so he can't
guarantee the outcome in civilian courts
and I don't know if you remember but in
the whole period after Tahrir Square
demonstrators were and even then it was
before Sisi but still they were being
put before military courts and there was
a big push saying civilians shouldn't be
put before military courts well now it's
even expanding in South Africa the
courts also remain quite independent and
we're really holding the line
and it was the Public Prosecution that
was particularly captured so that kind
of thing in Honduras there's something
called the quali Anza so I'm like what's
the quali anza quali Anza is an agency
that signs the contracts for big
infrastructure projects or programs
which are often public-private
partnerships exactly what we're being
you know anyone here about a 1.5
trillion dollar or anything right you
know public-private partnership what
happens is once it's a public-private
partnership the money is moved off of
the budget process so it is free from
public procurement you know obligations
and it's secret and in fact what I heard
is some of the banks that are holding
the trust funds for some of these
projects which are part of the network
even they are saying Rua I'm not sure I
want any more of these because the
government officials who are on the
Governing Council of the particular
project are siphoning so much off into
their own pockets
so quale Anza was one that for Honduras
I included so you can imagine and then
the government agencies that you can't
you can't actually capture I mean in
Honduras also it's just it's a little
bit of a the current president when he
had finished being president of Congress
so he ran for president as basically the
Speaker of the House and so in the time
between he took office as president in
the middle of the night he had Congress
fire four out of five Supreme Court
justices packed the court because
there's a presidential term limit in the
or there was in the Honduran
Constitution so just before he becomes
president he already knows he wants to
run for a second term he he changes the
Supreme Court which dutifully a year
later strikes down the constitutional
term limit Kuan Orlando Hernandez just
want one reelection in a very
questionable election so that's the kind
of thing I'm talking about you either
take over or
hallow out government institutions and
hollowing them out can mean not
appointing people to open positions it
can mean not paying them it can mean
rotating competent official officials
frequently or sending them essentially
to Siberia there was a really
extraordinary version of this in 2014
when the militaries of Iraq Nigeria and
Ukraine collapsed almost simultaneously
because each of them had been
essentially hollowed out cannibalized by
the kleptocratic networks that were
running those countries oh one other
point I just want to mention on the
private sector side so on the private
sector that can get really diabolical
like Tunisia one of Tunisia doesn't have
oil one of its really lucrative export
products is dates you know the fruit
because Muslims the world over break
their Ramadan fast with dates in
particular in the Gulf that's a big
market and Tunisia grows fantastic dates
so what's the constraint for growing
dates water right they grow in oases now
I used to think that the trees just grow
in the Oasis and they try to get water
well we're in the modern age now there
is public there's a public water
department that delivers the water is
you know in pipes and it's delivered to
the different orchards so I'm Ben Ali's
son-in-law
I want your dates and I want them at a
certain price and I tell you what price
I'm gonna take your dates for and if you
protest tomorrow you don't have any
water the tax authorities in country
after country now I know we can get
pissed off at the IRS and stuff like
that but in country after country
Tunisia being one who's Becca Stan being
another what I found out is
that taxes are sort of conditionally
forgiven so if you have a best business
that the network wants a piece of you
know so long as you give them your the
piece you don't have to pay any taxes
but let's say they come back and say you
know what 17% isn't enough I want 23%
you say I can't possibly give you 23% I
won't you know stay afloat bang tomorrow
you're audited for millions of dollars
so the tax authorities become not a
revenue generation you know for public
services so it's not a way of generating
revenue in order to pay for teachers and
and roads and trains and things like
that but instead it's a it's a
weaponization to keep people or it's a a
weapon to keep people online there's
another really important aspect of this
which is external enablers so how many
of you heard about the Panama papers or
paradise' papers right so what those are
secrecy jurisdictions the law firms and
registered agents that create the phony
companies for you in secrecy
jurisdictions the banks that you know
accept deposits re deposits from
corporations that are made in the name
of a cat that's a kind of enabler that's
a one cat that's really true that
actually happened somebody yeah did it
in Delaware with the picture of the cat
- oh I think I'd like to have this
corporation in the name of my cat isn't
he cute
and sure enough she was able to register
the corporation those are sort of
service providers right I mean it's kind
of first come first sir you know I mean
it's whoever you pays your money and you
get your service there are other types
of enablers that are even more kind of
painful to think about so I'm gonna do
one that's gonna hit really close to
home two or three years ago this
university gave an honorary degree to
and gauzy and she's got a hyphenated
last name the last part of which is a
koala
she was the finance minister of Nigeria
who presided over the loss of a billion
dollars a month in oil revenues that
never made it into the public coffers
she i'm not asserting that she stole any
of that money I do know that she was
finance minister when that was going on
I know that her colleague the governor
of the central bank found the evidence
provided a long memo with lots of
documentation to the Senate
the Nigerian Senate and was fired and
she never opened her mouth and she has
never from that day to this said a
negative word about the then president
of Nigeria either in private or in or in
public and in private I know because I
know the people in the State Department
so I was asking was she even saying
stuff was she providing you any
information behind the scenes nope
that's not the kind of person who
deserves a Yale honorary degree and it
happens all over the place and I'm
picking on you guys because it happens
to be a case that I got involved in
because I knew the chairman of your
board of trustees and I and so I wrote
her a letter a letter say Marky how can
you possibly be doing this you know and
but it happens all over the place
I mean think tanks are classics for this
and I've argued also with Carnegie they
they invited an Afghan official that I
was extremely unhappy about but it had
already happened by the time I found out
about it and that's you know I get it
that there are free speech issues and
this is a little bit different from
three speech this is giving awarding
people honors and these people are as
interested in laundering their images as
they are in laundering their money and
so it becomes a very important role I
think for prestigious institutions to be
a little bit careful about who who to
whom they are providing this kind of
award development assistance is another
really incredible one and on the
Honduras
effort I looked at development financing
which I hadn't really examined before so
what those are are banks that are public
institutions so I picked on again I like
picking on the night's people right
Finland one of the most wonderful
countries in the world extremely clean
and and uncorrupt itself they have
something called fin fund which is their
Development Bank and the thesis is if we
you know ally with the private sector to
provide loans rather than just giving
away development assistance we'll be
able to leverage more money and get more
of that stuff into the picture and
therefore presumably have more
development well I think there's some
folks I understand who have been in Iraq
as well as Afghanistan in the audience
here and we know those of us who have
been in those those two theaters that
there were no constraints on money there
was no limit on the quantity of
development money that got injected into
those two theaters did that produce any
more development not really I mean I
would submit that it's how you target
the money rather than the quantity of
dollars that really makes the difference
and so what I found with the Development
Bank's is they're so the Finnish Foreign
Ministry puts money in fin fund its
layered just like the secrecy
jurisdictions right Finnish Foreign
Ministry puts money into fin fund which
puts money into something called the
Central America
mezzanine infrastructure fund with some
undisclosed number of other investors so
already I can't even know the totality
of who else is invested in that fund fin
fund did not disclose to the Finnish
population how much of their money it
had invested infant in in Kamath which
is pretty shocking like why does that
have to be secret and then of course the
development
requirements what you know the people
who are then investing Kamath into
projects in Central America what are the
what are the criteria will that secret
to because there's a whole variety of
investors and so I working on the on the
on the issue could not get from the Finn
fund CEO what are the criteria then I go
to find the managers of Kamath and they
turn out to be a regular old private
equity firm based in Washington DC that
also manages the money of the sultan of
brunei so what and what I found it and
then I talked to fin fund about money
that they had invested directly and it
was really interesting in a project that
resulted in the assassination of an
absolutely wonderful environmental and
social activist a couple of years ago
and it was like Stockholm Syndrome they
said our clients are good people they at
least they're not putting their money in
Swiss banks at least they're reinvesting
it in you know hydroelectric dams and
stuff like that well-well go e that's
because they can make way more money on
the hydroelectric dams in Honduras than
they could in a Swiss bank because the
system is rigged so hydroelectric dams
count as renewable energy they get 10%
above market rate for the duration of
the contract which is 30 years for
quote-unquote renewable energy plus a33
cent per kilowatt hour bonus plus the
government guarantees it will buy every
single kilowatt that they generate so no
risk that's what and then they don't
even have to get the money because
they're getting money from Development
Bank's right that's why they're there
they're putting their money in and it
was fascinating when this whole project
blew up in in the face of thin fund and
at the end of the interview I said did
you did you learn anything from this
like is there anything that you would do
differently as a result of this and they
said yeah yeah it's not enough to have a
good project you have to really look at
the context in which and I think yes
they got it you know
and I said you really have to see
whether there's some powerful NGO that's
able to you know whip up world opinion
against such a good project and you know
then you have to abandon a really good
project if you're up against an NGO like
that I mean I'm filling in the dots but
that's that's what they said
so the completely battered down lenka
indigenous movement you know that was
the powerful NGO so sorry for that long
riff on enablers but the reason I pause
there is because there are all kinds of
ways of being an enabler
I wrote this big nasty report about
Honduras and the biggest bank in Central
America which has just been fingered for
laundering some of the money from you
know that guy who's dealing drugs who
pled guilty in in New York not his money
but his mother oh oh wait that's one
other thing I wanted to point out on the
private sector charity foundations I've
seen it everywhere so in Uzbekistan the
you know daughter of the President had a
charity that was called fund forum and
that was basically her black box so if I
wanted to invest in the telecom sector
in Uzbekistan I would have to pay the 27
percent to her but I also every once a
while would have to make a contribution
into fund for him and if I didn't the
towers would go down and my customers
wouldn't have any signal so the Clinton
Foundation let me just be very explicit
right I mean I don't know that influence
was actually bought what I do and I
presume they've got enough lawyers that
they stayed inside the letter of the law
that being said when the king of morocco
puts money into the Clinton Foundation
he certainly believes that he's buying
influence so that's why that that one is
so sensitive and I and I so I kind of
dwelling this because as I say
all of this applies to us I wrote this
report on Honduras the biggest banking
in Central America sued Carnegie for
defamation which they're not gonna win
right they as I say they're laundering
the money that Lobos wife put into one
of these charities in order to steal
welfare funds so there were welfare
funds designed for giving kids backpacks
and building various infrastructure
projects and she was siphoning that off
and it was running through this Bank I
was gonna write an op-ed about something
else to do with Honduras my boss said
Sarah come on knock it off well we've
got this case going on really
interesting huh they don't need to win
the case they they're a bank they have
infinite money what they were trying to
do was stop people from you know looking
too closely and it worked so I'm not
gonna say that Carnegie is an enabler
but I'm gonna say there's a whole bunch
of what I would call soft enablers
people who go to work at prestigious
institutions we don't have to work too
hard at Carnegie we don't have to
actually teach classes or anything like
that you know we have a decent salary we
don't have to show up on Fridays at in
the summer time it's a kind of cushy and
and we get to be you know like have a
good guys uniform so long as we don't
actually really get in the way too much
and I think that's led to some of where
we are now in the United States I think
that we've all been asleep at the switch
as our own kleptocratic system has been
developing and kind of crystallizing and
reinforcing itself over the last two or
three decades
note that this is ideology free it's
really critical back in the 20
century we had this idea that there were
these ideologies pitted against each
other now the threat to government in
the public interest is ideology free and
I've seen it both here so I've just
mentioned the left the left/right
versions of it in the US I've seen it in
Latin America where Venezuela and Brazil
cut one way and Honduras and Guatemala
cut the other way and there each one is
as kleptocratic as the other and so
saying this is about too much public
sector involvement in the political
economy or too much private sector
involvement of the political economy is
wrong it's about how what are the checks
and what is the oversight on how the
political economy runs and you know you
see it in genuinely authoritarian
countries like Azerbaijan and you see it
in you know at least nominal democracies
by legalizing and normalizing
kleptocratic practices those countries
can slip toward becoming kleptocracy and
in that context electoral politics
starts to look to ordinary people a lot
more like intra or inter network rivalry
not really you know about who's got
better public policies and that's why a
lot of people don't vote and that's why
a lot of the indigenous people in
Honduras were saying hey after a while
we realized these two parties neither of
them had our interests at heart but they
were pitting us against each other
doesn't that sound familiar a couple of
other characteristics of kleptocratic
governance in our day and age a lot of
that stuff right we're not talking petty
crime here a billion dollars a month in
Nigeria that's a lot of money it's not
victimless and this is really critical
it's not even as indirect as we often
think it is so the victims are of course
all of us who are lacking in
you know our not receiving the type of
public service and government in our
interest that we deserve that is our
inalienable right but you know when you
get shaken down by a cop on a road in
southern Afghanistan or northern Nigeria
they they don't they don't ask you
nicely right and if they did you
probably are you Afghan by any chance
yeah what's your name
Adam yes so Adam I you know you've got a
cousin in the force
you know how low our salaries are right
I've got three kids at home and I need
shoes for my youngest could you please
help me out
the guy would pull the money out of his
pocket and give it to me but that's not
how it happens you get insulted you get
treated with contempt you get smacked
you get you know and you know I mean it
and I start thieves of state with this
story where it's one of my guys or one
of my kind of extended family who got
smacked in the face by a police officer
because he refused to pay the bribe and
I thought we would have to bail him out
of jail I mean you are a 20-something
year old Afghan male former member of
the police himself
you've got dignity and sometimes that's
all you've got and and so you know and
that's money right and we've been
talking about that stuff but when I had
this conversation with justice sector
professionals in northern Nigeria a
prosecutor said you know Sarah you're
just talking about money but it's not
just about money so in the me to era he
this was before the me to era he tells
me about the judge who had a guy in on
preventive detention who's diabetic the
guy's wife begs the judge says police
he's diabetic I have to give him his
medicine I promise I will deliver him to
the courtroom on time the judge takes
advantage of her
that's another version of me to write
it's called sextortion and that's really
what went on with Weinstein that was
sextortion
it was not sexual I mean sexual
harassment is another way of putting it
sexual assault is another way but it's
extortion but not for money for services
as a female you all know how I feel
about that as a security professional
I'm thinking about my guy in the cop in
Kandahar and I'm thinking about this
lady's brother what does he want to do
he wants to shoot the judge just like my
guy wanted to shoot the cop and when you
live in southern Afghanistan or northern
Nigeria you almost have to try not to
join Boko Haram or the Taliban there's
plenty of people who want you to shoot
the cop right so you get smacked in the
face by a cop enough times you know
you're gonna want to pick up that gun
and shoot it or some piece some of them
will and so this is how we get to
extremism and I can develop that
argument further there actually is a
pretty interesting argument because a
lot peer admittin puritanical religious
movements make an anti-corruption
argument and that's true in Islam today
as I say the militant puritanical wing
of Islam today and it was true in
Christianity in our own history in the
Netherlands in Puritans they were making
the same argument they were radical
religious extremists making an
anti-corruption argument actually and so
there's a I'll give away the punchline a
little bit but there's a place so John
Locke right who's had to read him yeah I
didn't but it's actually really worth
reading I read him for when I didn't in
school and I read him as I was working
on theives estate and I found like I let
out a yell when I found the following
thought when there is a barefaced
resting of the law like grabbing of the
law - basically I think he uses the word
indemnified but it's to serve the
purposes of
a man or a party of men war is made on
the sufferers very strong language war
is made on the sufferers who lacking an
appeal on earth to write them will turn
to the only remedy in such cases an
appeal to heaven so he's basically
predicting violent religious insurgency
as an you know as a reaction to systemic
corruption it's pretty cool so I laid
that side-by-side with it and if I had
the book I could does anyone have the
book yeah let me see if I can find this
quickly thank you if I get it fast no
not there yeah sorry let me just if yeah
yeah
[Music]
I don't think I quite of it
that's a TIA and that's Oh a hurry I
don't want to drag you through this but
in either chapter 13 or chapter 14 you
will find Osama bin Laden saying just
about the same thing it's really
remarkable you put those two
side-by-side and it's almost
word-for-word and so so that's extremism
the
Arab Spring revolutions and euromaidan I
mean when I was hearing about the Arab
Spring revolutions at first I kept
hearing about youth bulge and these sort
of structural things when I went and
actually traveled across Morocco Tunisia
I skipped Libya Egypt for Admiral Mullen
it was all about corruption I mean it
could not have been more explicit it was
you know people behind bars you know
pictures of ministers behind bars and
today we are almost living in a second
Arab Spring it saps action absolutely
remarkable but it's it's from so many
different countries that we're seeing it
you know in you know separately but
there's Guatemala Brazil I just did a
paper on anti-corruption protests
Guatemala Brazil Burkina Faso South
Africa Romania lots of Eastern Europe
countries are in it but I looked at
Romania Lebanon the youth you stink
protests South Korea it is now the
number one cause of the toppling of
rulers of governments Iceland they
kicked out their or their prime minister
fell after the Panama papers came out
these are massive popular movements
against corruption
what I discovered however that's really
problematic is that there's a tendency
to sort of see the individual
or head of state as the personification
of the corruption that bothers everyone
and to go for the unseating of the head
of state a network is an incredibly
resilient structure think of a fishing
net and you know the fisherman will will
mend their nets all winter but you know
if you've got one of those strands
broken on a fishing net the net still
works and so I've been watching all over
the place
kleptocratic networks basically
sacrifice their rulers their heads to
the crowd and I've also seen them fight
back very effectively by playing on
identity divides that's one of the most
successful ways to kleptocratic Network
stay in power in Lebanon it was
particularly egregious because they were
actually sending text messages to
individuals telling them you know don't
go out to that to that protest it's an
amount s tor that's what that protest is
a hezbollah protest but tragically it
wasn't just a network that was doing
that the opposition was also playing up
the identity divide so it was largely a
bunch of you know who started it was
largely Siddha fide educated Bay Rudy's
after a while people start coming down
from the hills and the poor Shiite kids
start flooding up from the southern
ghettos of Beirut and you that was they
like the the the leaders of the movement
they didn't really want to be with the
Shiite riffraff so they separated it out
and told the Shiite riffraff to go to
this square while they kept martyr
square and they even prevented their own
people from going to join the Shiite
riffraff so of course the the movement
fell apart I think that has very
profound implications for us where I
have found the focus on identity divides
is as intense
both sides of the political divide it
really is so the tax law turns out I
didn't learn this until like last week
our tax law still new tax law still
gives a subsidy to offshoring
business operations if you run your
business entirely in the United States
you pay twenty one percent tax if you
move your operations offshore you pay at
most ten percent and usually zero I
haven't heard a lot of Democrats
screaming about that I heard a lot of
repeal repeal repeal Obamacare repeal
from the day it passed repeal where's
our repeal the tax the tax law
why is that not the you know and so I'm
hearing dakka dakka dakka and I get that
and that's important I'm just saying
the proportion of focus on daca which
frankly is an identity issue as opposed
to economic justice is pretty shocking
and we can go down that you know Lane
there's a lot more to be said about that
okay I think I'll sort of think about
wrapping up now but what I want to say
is when I wrote this book what I meant
by why corruption threatens global
security is that it drives people to
extremes extremes like joining extremist
movements having revolutions which
devolve into massively bloody disasters
like Syria or voting for you know
comedians like they did in Italy or
Guatemala or but that is I mean extreme
voting patterns right and that's what I
thought was the danger of corruption now
I think that the kind of network
corruption I've been talking about is
the danger in and of itself that is the
threat to government in the public
interest and it's really insidious it's
not the Nazis or the Soviets it doesn't
wear a uniform it's all of us and so
it's gonna be really hard to fight and
let me just say again a little are there
any historians in a row yeah right
so roughly right back before democracy
and I know that goes back quite a while
because we've had democracy you know in
a number of different eras but the deal
was the ruler goes through a kind of
sacred right a rite of passage a
coronation or an investiture wherein he
or she is in a kind of sacred way
expected to lay aside usually his
private identity as a private person and
take on this new identity as defender of
the public interest and Henry the fourth
first and second parts really get at
that issue there's someone who at least
in the play does that and it's pretty
surprising to a bunch of his pals for
him back from when he was a private
person but most of them didn't right
most rulers didn't do that and so human
society started coming up with
constraints to force them to think and
act in the public interest and and and I
found fascinating as I thought about it
that the first of those constraints was
law right the first constraint was not
suffrage was not voting so in democracy
in the in the path toward democracy the
first step along that path is forced the
king to submit to law magna carta
Dutch Revolt English Civil War in the
English Civil War which comes up in
themes of state what's so fascinating is
Charles the first gets put on trial they
could have just assassinated the guy in
a dark corner they decided to put him on
trial and Charles was got it he
understood how incredibly revolutionary
that was to subject the ruler to laws
made by men and so he refused to enter a
plea he knew he would die that was a
guaranteed death sentence but for him
the principle was
important enough that he accepted
certain death rather than subject
himself to two law the second constraint
is suffrage but as I've just described
these kleptocratic networks have
disabled significantly disabled both of
these constraints and that's the
situation that we're up against so if we
believe in government by and for the
people whatever our political persuasion
that's what's important here we're gonna
have to fight for it and do it we have
to start now and I think I'm not quite
sure yet what form that fight needs to
take for each of us but let me just I've
just got a couple of little points here
number one and I really wish I had made
this point at a prior talk I just gave
at the world affairs council at Hilton
Head in South Carolina so those people
have a most of them have a fair amount
of income or did first point pay your
taxes I think pretty much everyone in
this room is unlikely to be the type of
person who spends a lot of money on
getting out of their taxes but I suspect
that people at my Hilton Hilton had
audience maybe they are that kind of
people or some of them might have been
pay your taxes right like like that's
part of pop and in stop like we have to
stop whining about them the teachers in
West Virginia the reason they're being
paid with a slingshot is because no one
in West Virginia wants to pay their
taxes stop turning a blind eye to our
own side since that's you know like
there's a tendency to say corruption
happens over there we almost have to
look at our own political family first
then transparency is really important
this business of being able to start a
company without declaring the real
beneficiary of that company company is
ridiculous there's a
now a law or a bill making its way
through Congress to end beneficial
what's called beneficial ownership
secrecy so you might take a look at that
and I know it sounds obscure compared to
the other things you're calling your
members of Congress about but that's an
important one revolving door I think is
really a really big issue in terms of
the reform program that we're gonna need
we're gonna have to limit the ability of
people to go directly from industry into
government and directly from government
back into industry we're seeing it now
where we've got former lobbyists are now
running the agencies that they lobbied
against and we saw it in the opioid
crisis unbelievable investigative work
by the wash Washington Post and 60
minutes where DEA prosecutors literally
walked out the door got hired by the
drug companies and took the entire
prosecution strategy over to the drug
companies meanwhile drug companies are
leaning on Congress and the DEA to quit
it and that's why we have you know 200
people that's 200,000 people dead it's
absolutely unconscionable and then
finally in what I'm what I'm thinking
about some of these issues like
transparency in revolving door and and
you know disclosed your tax returns and
things like that I mean we could start
thinking about a litmus you know what
about building just like there was the
no new taxes test for candidates or the
pro-abortion or anti-abortion test what
about having three or five integrity and
government points that we as citizens
would start to champion doesn't matter
who you vote for Republican or Democrat
anyone you know who wants our support
needs to sign up to the following three
or four principles and then hold them
accountable and finally we got to figure
out how to honor values other than that
stuff and that means people and that's a
lot of the people in this room I think
but people who have chosen the
profession that other than that
something other than maximize their
returns those people need to be able to
make a decent living so they don't need
to be rewarded with more money but they
need to have enough money to have a
dignified life and we have to figure out
how we reallocate things so that it's
not all you know the people in the
competition for zeros are sucking all of
the resources out of the rest of the
system thank you very much
[Applause]
for thoughts questions arguments don't
be shy thank you would you mind just
telling me who you are just like one
word about like where you fit into this
right what you essentially have a and so
my question is how do you differentiate
between corruption and taxation if the
money isn't being used for example well
it is I mean look at China it is being
so so that's the differentiation
taxation the money goes back into the
public good now you may disagree with
how that money is spent you one might
disagree but it said but it is not going
into pockets sure is oh yes he is
no no but the police officer isn't he's
in extracting bribes in the US but in
Afghanistan believe me the police
officers who are taking Brides are doing
way better than their neighbors
honestly now they may not be sending it
to you know Dubai but believe me that
was one of the problems as the people
skimming the development contracts you
had you know 17 year-olds driving 40,000
50,000 hundred thousand dollar cars and
everybody knew how much because they
could speak English and they got jobs
with contractors and things like that
and it was it was salary but it was also
what they were skimming on the side so
that is the difference the difference is
when the money is siphoned off for
private ends which it is in Azerbaijan
and it is in China and that's why she is
running an anti-corruption campaign now
he may be doing it also to you know
consolidate his power but corruption is
a gigantic issue in China we don't see
it because there isn't you know we're
not but there are hundred there there
like every year about a hundred thousand
demonstrations large and small in China
over corruption we're not seeing it
because they're able to keep a lid on it
but but that's an incredibly corrupt so
so it's not really legitimate I would
argue that it will always blow up at one
point or another it will blow up in
different ways but it'll blow up so you
don't always get a religious insurgency
you might get an ideological insurgency
you might get a revolution you might get
mass public protests it's it it's so so
another kind of visual I have and I've
never really taken this as far as I
should but it's a kind of corruption and
security map and it's the different
types of security crisis that have been
generated by by acute corruption and
then the watch countries but it's I mean
that is a good question and some you
know because like why does the pop why
is the population in Russia not really
blowing up they did they did though
Iran also they did in 2009 we forget
they do you don't always succeed in
toppling the government but you know you
can even consider the Iranian Revolution
to be one of these and so but but astute
use of national mythology and identity
divides is one way the network keeps you
know keep stays in control so in Russia
the whole nationalistic rhetoric and
Mother Russia and stuff like that is
keeping people largely in line and Putin
has really work in that very well in
India you know they still have the
vestiges of a system that said oh the
people on top are meant to be on top
it's supposed to be that way that's the
national mythology it's starting to
break down but not fast enough and I was
just in Nepal doing a workshop on how
their kleptocratic network is structured
and this came out that this is a real
break on public protest against it and
frankly I would submit than in the
United States the myth of upward
mobility has also kept us a lot quieter
than we ought to be over the last thirty
years yeah some of your recommendations
and it seems to me so my question to you
is is that is that really the suggestion
that you
to make to those people or are you truly
wasting your time for the most part
someone that might might resonate well
howdee in other words let me another way
if we're afraid of rephrasing the
question how do you do you really expect
to generate any kind of support
okay I think I think not from real
Network members no there you have to
work on incentive structures but this
was a crowd that thinks these were the
soft enablers this particular crowd
these or among they thought of
themselves think of themselves as
incredibly upstanding they they were in
love with this I mean I obviously didn't
give the exact same talk but you know it
was these sorts of issues they loved it
and that's why they were the right ones
you know to really sort of right then
and there say hey we're all playing a
little bit hypocritical here but but I
do think those of us who do want to get
into the fight there are things we can
do in our everyday lives and that is one
of them I mean I suspect that you know
we're I doubt that many people in this
room are spending a lot of money evading
taxes however I suspect that we might
you know be trying to minimize as much
as we can and what I'm what I'm
suggesting is don't put that much energy
into it or what I'm suggesting is if
your credit card comes from one of the
banks that was really significant and
bringing about you know the crash of
2008 and I didn't think of this until I
mean I Bank at HSBC which is one of the
classic facilitators right in France and
I just you know and I've intended for
the last five years to get out of that
Bank and I still haven't bothered right
I mean we have to inconvenience
ourselves I did switch finally go online
and I don't know what I googled to get
the coalition for banking on values and
it's an
International Coalition of banks that
agree to sign up to a certain series of
principles in terms of how they you know
who they lend to etc etc etc and I
decided heck I'm gonna get one of my
credit card from one of them I mean I
think there are ways in our daily lives
that we can begin working to change the
incentive structure that's not going to
defeat this Hydra I get it you're
exactly right the Hydra is gonna have to
get defeated by much more militant
action much more militant action but
what I'm what I'm saying from my
experience with the protests in
Guatemala in Brazil and and and and
Burkina Faso I think is that's an
interesting one to watch I think they're
doing it doing pretty well but the
window of opportunity for reform will be
really narrow you know at some point the
head of this Hydra is going to come down
of our Hydra is going to come down the
question is number one will the network
stay in place so let me again just get
real explicit about the implications for
America
I'm not a big impeachment fan I mean I
think that if impeachment is warranted
that's fine but don't assume that
impeachment would be a panacea because
the rest of the network is still going
to be in place so that so so in a way
it's gonna have to be much deeper than
that and then there's gonna be a very
quick window of opportunity before the
network regroups and that means you know
the reform package better be ready to go
and we all better be ready to fight to
put it in there and that's why you know
some of those items were on it I think
it'll be interesting to what I mean it's
interesting to watch the gun issue right
now and watch you know so there's a
moment where it's been a moment of
opportunity window of opportunity the
kids are doing great the NRA and company
is scrambling a little bit but not for
long not for long and they are already
you know you already see the
representatives pivoting to you say what
are you gonna do about gun control and
they say you know mental health is
really a big
that got their talking points and you
know and has anyone read dark money all
right if you were interested in this
topic go home and buy it right now and
this is a book that I've had on my shelf
for a year and I've only started reading
it right now and and what is so I think
she leaves out half the story which is
the kind of defection of the other
political camp frankly to the same
principles but it tells the story of a
group of people who considered
themselves completely shut out from
politics and where it was going and
policy national policy on economic
issues they had a whole lot of money
basically infinite money and they set
out over a 30-year period to win control
over our political economy they mostly
come out of the fossil fuel world not
exclusively but largely massively Massa
you know it's the billionaires certain
it's a subset of billionaires and what's
so stunning to me is number one they
felt as shut out as let's say Bernie
supporters do right now and they
methodically planned what they were
gonna do about it and they had a really
long view and at the moment they
achieved what they were after
so the point there is you know yes it's
possible but it's gonna take real
sustained effort and unfortunately most
of the money is on the side of
government not in the public interest
most of the money is on the side of
government in corporate interest but as
I say the other thing that's really
dangerous is the identity divided and
until we can get the single mother from
the ghetto in Baltimore together with
the unemployed coal miner in West
Virginia or in Western Maryland and
there's a college that does that it's a
cut its a UMD campus it's Frostburg it
just happens its student body is
precisely that it's kids from the inner
city of Baltimore and farmers kids from
from West Virginia and and I'm really
interested to know do they find common
ground or do they spend their time
focusing do they find the common
economic justice ground or do they focus
on their cultural identity divides and I
don't know that yet yes because you're
differently you might be insulted by
this one of the five best guest speakers
I've ever heard you I don't dare almost
don't dare ask you what we should do
about our electoral system in the United
States which makes sense cowards out of
everybody and it would of me to any get
the money out of it get the money out of
it
we have got if it has to be a
constitutional amendment if it's
terrifying to go down the constitutional
road I don't know the idea that money
equals speech is so utterly preposterous
the idea that you can have secret money
in electoral campaigns is completely
preposterous how can that have happened
how can that have happened in France
where I'm actually a resident they have
campaign spending limits they have
extremely rigorous rules about what you
can spend campaign money on so for
example you can't just put posters up
anywhere there is a set of boards in
front of the polling places that's where
you're allowed to put posters we've got
to write and I feel that's more
important even than electoral college
and stuff like that I frankly and I I
mean I'm not decided about whether the
electoral college is a bad thing or not
I mean I do feel perhaps that some of
the under
presented communities like rural
communities deserve you know more of a
say than their absolute population might
give them but and it's interesting
there's a wonderful writer from Kentucky
called Wendell Barry have you ever heard
of him
he writes he's incredible he's about 90
now I think but this is a guy who grew
up in Kentucky was a journalist for a
while went back and started farming and
with a [ __ ] with horses and he's got
really interesting things to say about
the rural economy and the whole sort of
system and disenfranchisement of rural
people so he's writing way before what's
happened recently but it almost presages
it but one of the things he did in a
fairly in a 2005 or 6 essay was to
substitute the words the way that
small-town people are referred to like
in a New Yorker or New York time no New
York Review of Books was one of the
articles that he quoted you know narrow
minded like a country lawyer stuff like
that and he said just exchange Jew or
black or whatever like nobody could get
away with talking like that about
country people the contempt that pours
out of urban people about country people
is true so anyway that's about electoral
college I'm not sure what's the way to
go on that but the money in the system
is it's so bad so first of all it allows
for the capture of our elected officials
but even where the money doesn't
actually buy victory which it doesn't
always it creates a primary if you need
X million dollars in order to run for
office
it means you have to spend X amount of
your time with people who are capable of
giving that much money now there are
lots of corollaries to that that means
you're listening to what they want more
than you're listening to what ordinary
people want but it also means you have
to be the kind of
person who's comfortable in a room with
people who could give you half a million
dollars I'm not sure I want all of my
elected representatives to be people who
are comfortable in that kind of room of
a community you know so for me that's
number one and and I don't know how we
do it it you know given Citizens United
I guess you need a constitutional
amendment I don't know we had no we
don't row it could it could be
overturned but not by this court so sir
in the back and then down there yes I
don't but you're saying it would be a
sort of read map applied to the
Constitution right what I'm what i meant
by read map is read map was the plan to
read redistricting which went via first
capture in state legislatures and then
they use big data to draw these
ridiculous districts now the next the I
wouldn't be surprised I have not heard
this but these guys are that strategic
dead
social yeah
really interesting question I think that
social media has facilitated some of the
protests that we've seen we've obviously
seen now social media being you
weaponized by anti-democratic
individuals and institutions and forces
but I think it's a tool not an end in
itself you know and a tool can be used
for good or for you it kind of comes to
that but interestingly in burkina faso i
talked to some of the people who had
helped generate the gigantic demonstrate
you know protests there and it was like
rap singers and stuff like that and they
use social media but they also did what
they called citizenship tara vans and
they would drive their motorcycles into
the neighborhoods they'd set up a stage
have a concert and then at intermission
they'd have a debate about citizenship
and they'd be talking about you know so
they did retail politics as a you know
as a festive kind of thing and then they
not only toppled a dictator they also
thwarted an attempted coup to reinstate
the network so that was pretty cool so i
actually am thinking in those directions
to i mean i finally finally started
tweeting i not Facebook it's just too
much self exposure I just I you know but
tweeting and it was Trump that got me to
tweet because I realized that he's
actually conveying you know original
material and so for example I did a
Rachel Maddow interview and I really
dammit I forgot to say the following
three things so I thought wow if I I
could tweet
those you know and then so you know but
I I have the feeling that the the wave
is cresting on social media the other
really interesting thing about social
media is that it makes it harder for
these guys to hide so one of the really
interesting elements of the Arab Spring
was Bahrain I don't know if anyone
remember Bahrain is this it's like it's
like The Princess and the pea Bahrain is
the pea that sits between Iran and Saudi
Arabia like you know and it is I think
one-fifth the size of Rhode Island and
has the population of Rhode Island and
as its population discovered because of
Google Maps that population is shoved
down into one third of the island and
that's part of what sent them over the
edge during the Arab Spring was those
maps came out and they realized oh my
god this is like the West Bank is like
the Shiite West Bank they're sitting in
this tiny little while the royal family
has two-thirds of the island and they
had a third of the total population in
the streets you had one all right so you
know Wendell Berry is the guy still
alive I want to go visit him I think
he's an absolute talk about a national
treasure
accents because like fifty-five percent
of it goes to national security well I
think that's an issue and but then once
you've paid your taxes then you start
leaning on your representatives to
reduce the defense budget but not paying
taxes means your teachers don't get paid
your you know no no public anything and
it means that so that's a separate issue
but I believe in the public service and
then we can get into an argument about
what our taxes are paid for if or what
what they're used for and you know I
mean if there are certainly lines that a
government could cross like if our
government truly becomes captured there
are lines that it might cross that would
cause me to say okay I go into revolt
and but at that point you know then
you're in revolt and we might have to
get there I mean this could get
extremely ugly let me just point to
another I don't want to be too alarmist
but kleptocratic networks everywhere
I've looked at them have a non an
informal instrument of force at their
disposal
so in Honduras you guys remember the
kids who were streaming across the
border and still are starting 2014 so I
kept hearing about gangs absortion gang
extortion gang extortion when I got
there I started thinking about to where
second gang extortion where I come from
the police extort and I said I wonder if
the police are outsourcing their
extortion to the gangs bingo so the gang
serve as an informal auxiliary for the
police they extort for the police
keeping some so basically the police
lets them extort so long as they pay
some up the line and then when the
police need need to rub somebody out
they send the gangs after them
so in Egypt you had the thugs you know
on the camels that went into Tahrir
Square so think back to Charlotte's
ville that was described often
as you know the president is cozying up
to his voting base I said no I don't
think so I think that's the president
cultivating a put a potential informal
instrument of force if the Wolves really
start snapping at his door could he
might he incite riot I mean I think it's
not impossible
exactly exactly but I'm not sure those
are not I'm not sure those are exclusive
mutually exclusive that's a version of
you know what and I made you introduce
yourself and then I totally forgot to
make everybody else I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to pick on you I meant to
pick on everybody and I now realize
you're Gabe right Dave right right so
that's a version of Dave's question why
do some people why does it explode in
some places and not in others and it's
that's a little hard to tell all I can
say is you know so Iceland Iceland had
been through a really significant crisis
after the economic collapse of 2008 and
they they did a really interesting thing
which is first of all a prime minister
fell over that one - and then there was
a constitution writing exercise where it
was online and ordinary citizens could
modifications and stuff like that they
could make recommendations and so they
revise their constitution but the
network beat them off and it never
passed in Parliament so there was
already quite a you know intense anger
among the people of Iceland about this
network there so I think they were
primed you know to go after him
Argentina
I just don't know and it's funny we have
a at Carnegie one Latin America guy
Moises Naim who's a four who's Venezuela
and then a former minister I think and I
took my whole kleptocratic network
analysis to him and said I'm planning on
doing Honduras and he looked at the
thing and he said oh my god this is
great
don't waste your time on Honduras do
Argentina and and I was like Moses
I have never set foot in Latin America
before please let me have a little
country first and it took me a year to
do Honduras but so I just don't feel
that I know enough intimately about
Argentina
say - to know what what the secret sauce
is that makes people you know rise up I
mean what was it that's the spark why
was it what was it in Korea South Korea
what was it in you know and and and in
South Korea was revelations but somehow
they were even more shocking maybe
whatever came out in Panama papers
wasn't quite shocking enough to the
people of Argentina
that it put them into the streets okay
oh great thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]